[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit kaiser
über dichter und marietta slomka
guten abend sechs monate ist es nun
schon her dass russland seinen nachbarn
überfiel und damit auch eine schockwelle
durch ganz europa schickte vom
kriegsbeginn ist heute oft die rede doch
eigentlich ist das nicht zutreffend den
krieg gegen die ukraine begann russland
bereits 2014 mit der aktion der krim und
der besetzung von teilen der ost ukraine
wo moskau seitdem eigene leute und
kollaborateure herrschen lässt die sich
separatisten nennen was die russen am 24
februar diesen jahres versuchten war
diesen krieg endgültig für sich zu
entscheiden und auch in kiew war sein zu
installieren dieser plan ging
bekanntlich nicht auf aus dieser
erfolgreichen abwehr ziehen die ukraine
ihre kraft gerade heute an ihrem
nationalfeiertag hannah hebestreit
berichtet aus kiew
wenigstens für ein paar schnelle fotos
sagen sich am nationalfeiertag doch noch
viele menschen hier in kiew auf die
straße getraut die kulisse ist rostig
riecht verbrannt und ist ramponiert es
sind ukrainische trophäen aus sechs
monaten kampf gegen die russischen
angreifer
dieses jahr ist alles anders jetzt
verstehen wir was unser kampf für die
unabhängigkeit damals bedeutet hat und
was unabhängigkeit tatsächlich damals
jetzt haben wir eine vorstellung was wir
verlieren könnten wir können tatsächlich
alles verlieren davon hatte ich vorher
keine ahnung
er konnte bei der letzten großen parade
zum unabhängigkeitstag vor einem jahr
nicht ahnen was für die ukraine heute
auf dem spiel steht wahrscheinlich hat
er auch nicht damit gerechnet nach einem
halben jahr krieg ganz alleine zwischen
zerschossenen russischen panzern zu
stehen und durchhalteparole zu verkünden
erst wollten wir nur frieden jetzt
wollen wir den sieg mit einem
terroristischen regime kann man nicht
verhandeln
auch in diesem krieg geht es um die
macht der bilder
die sollen auch den menschen die seit
monaten am verteidigen mut machen diese
jungen ukrainischen kämpfer gerade mal
anfang zwanzig filme selbst ihren alltag
rund um ihre panzer an der front aktiv
in sozialen netzwerken erzählen sie von
tragischen erlebnisse
ich hatte hier fünf kameraden in meinem
alter heute sind noch zwei am leben ich
kann das gar nicht glauben ich kann
nicht beschreiben wie es mir damit geht
und so wie denken sie heute auch der
nach offiziellen regierungsangaben
9000 ukrainischen soldaten die im kampf
gegen solche waffen gefallen sind oder
eher weiter bestehenden gefahr einer
atomaren katastrophe weit über die
ukraine hinaus
residenzen lenski am abend vor dem
un-sicherheitsrat
eindringlich gewarnt
die internationale atomenergie behörde
muss so schnell wie möglich die ständige
kontrolle des atomkraftwerks borussia
übernehmen russland muss sich
zurückziehen und mit der nuklearen
erpressung auf
es ist ein stiller unabhängigkeitstag
der ihnen den wert ihrer unabhängigkeit
klar macht
und dann schalten wir noch zu unserem
reporter hebestreit nach kiew es gab ja
auch heute in der ukraine wieder
schweren beschuss
ja das ist eine schlimme nachrichten die
wir gehören von 15 toten und deutlich
mehr verletzten ist die rede das hat
präsident sie lenski vor dem
weltsicherheitsrat heute abend verkündet
danach ist wohl beim angriff auf einen
eisernen sparens station der in der
region von mikro einem zug getroffen
worden es gab auch noch einen zweiten
angriff auf eine andere eisenbahn in
richtung im westen des landes da haben
wir nicht gehört ob es verletzte oder
tote gegeben hat hier in kiew hatten wir
acht oder neun und dreizehn mal den
luftalarm gehört bislang jetzt hier zum
glück nichts passiert wollen wir hoffen
dass das in der nacht auch so bleibt
wir haben jetzt eben einen bericht ja
gehört präsident selensky der hat schon
auch die tonlage verschärft etwa wenn er
sagt erst wollten wir nur frieden und
jetzt wollen wir den sieg
ich denke damit greift eine stimmung in
der bevölkerung auch die wir auch immer
wieder hören wenn wir hier interviews
machen angesichts von mittlerweile
eingeräumten 9000 toten soldaten kann er
sich den russen gegenüber nicht
nachgiebig zeigen das wäre so etwas wie
politischer selbstmord in der
bevölkerung werden diese toten als opfer
gesehen und dieses opfer nicht umsonst
gewesen seien militärisch hat die
ukraine nicht wahnsinnig viel zu bieten
es gibt aber diese nadelstiche auf der
krim oder auch unten im süden hingegen
von jean hoffmann die nachschublinien
der russen immer wieder empfindlich
stören kann das lässt natürlich
spielraum offen für solche
interpretationen danke schön herr nach
kann die ukraine diesen krieg gewinnen
die frage habe ich vorhin der deutschen
außenministerin gestellt vor dem
interview mit annalena baerbock fast
annegret oster noch einmal die
ereignisse der letzten sechs monate
zusammen eine chronologie des krauts
luftalarm über kies
die russische invasion am anfang
flächendeckend putin attackiert mit
luftschlägen und raketenangriffen die
menschen erschüttert fast ungläubig
fliehen aus ihrem land
bitte bleiben sie ruhig wir sind stark
wir sind auf alles vorbereitet und wir
werden jeden besiegen denn wir sind die
ukraine
alles sieht nach einem blitzkrieg aus
aber die ukraine verteidigen sich
entschlossen mit allem was sie haben
putins plant jetzt schnell einzunehmen
scheitert der abzug der aggressoren aus
der region enthüllt das grauen mehr als
1000 tote zivilisten hunderte allein in
butter teilweise gefesselt mit
folterspuren viele in massengräbern
verscharrt roger wird zum synonym für
mutmaßliche kriegsverbrechen
wochenlang belagern russische truppen
die hafenstadt mariupol im süden des
landes menschen harren in kellern aus es
fehlt an nahrung und trinkwasser solchen
drohen nach der aufgabe des stahlwerks
auf stahl feld mariupol endgültig an den
aggressor der anfang juli auch die
donbass region luhansk unter seine
kontrolle bringt doch die ukraine wehrt
sich mit waffen aus dem westen das
wichtigste betont ihr präsident aber
immer wieder sei der anschluss an den
westen ohne
die ukraine wird es nie eine vollwertige
europäische macht bilden nur eines hat
russlands aggressiven drang zur
eroberung seiner nachbarn beeinflusst
dass die ukraine ein zerbrochenes stück
europa irgendwo außerhalb der grenzen
eurer länder ist
grenzübergreifend ist aktuell die sorge
vor einer nuklearen katastrophe seit
ende juli wird das von russen besetzte
größte atomkraftwerk europas in sapporo
schier beschossen moskau und kiew machen
sich gegenseitig dafür verantwortlich
und die deutsche aussenminister und es
sonst aus berlin zugeschaltet guten
abend frau berbalk
sehr guten abend einen blick auf diesen
krieg der nun seit sechs monaten wert
oder noch wenn man 2014 dazu nimmt noch
viel länger haben sie gesagt die ukraine
muss gewinnen kann sie dann auch
gewinnen
das wissen wir nicht so brutal ist die
realität aber wir werden alles dafür tun
dass es diese möglichkeit gibt und daher
weiter solidarisch die ukraine
unterstützen und dieser tag heute ist ja
nicht nur der tag sechs monate brutaler
angriffskrieg in der ukraine sondern
eigentlich war es mal ein ukrainischer
feiertag nämlich der unabhängigkeitstag
und das macht umso mehr deutlich worum
die ukraine kämpfte für frieden für
freiheit für ihr land aber eben auch für
die europäische friedensordnung und
deswegen ist es eigentlich ein weckruf
an uns auch noch mal alles zu überprüfen
wie wir die ukrainerinnen und ukrainer
bei ihrem kampf bei ihrem recht auf
selbstverteidigung weiter unterstützen
können und finden sie das wenn sie das
überprüfen dass deutschland da genug tut
das ist ja dieser schmale grat dem wir
seit wochen und monaten eigentlich gehen
dass wir militärisch sie unterstützen
wollen mit allem was wir haben das aber
leider der zustand ja auch bei uns so
ist dass wir gerade in unseren eigenen
beständen absolute defizite haben
deswegen wir 100 milliarden euro noch
mal selber besprochen beschlossen haben
für die bundeswehr weswegen wir
zusätzlich jetzt gesagt haben dass in
der rüstungsindustrie
dezidiert für die ukraine material
produziert werden muss und der kanzler
hat ja gerade auch noch einmal deutlich
gemacht dass das jetzt nicht nur für die
nächsten monate gilt sondern auch mit
blick auf die nächsten jahre und wir
diese militärische unterstützung
deutlich fortführen werden wer die
waffenlieferungen die der bundeskanzler
jetzt angekündigt hat die sind ja für
2023 aber jetzt wird gekämpft jetzt
steht der winter bevor und das ist
insofern auch ganz interessant ihr
amtskollege der ukrainische
aussenminister kollege hat jetzt gerade
bei unseren kollegen von den tagesthemen
in hamburg gesagt dass die lieferung und
schneller und kontinuierliche erfolgen
sollten
und das stimmt und die äußerung von
außenminister kollegen aus der ukraine
herrn kollegen schließen sich mit den
äußerungen von herrn scholz nicht aus
sondern sie ergänzen einander denn wir
brauchen jetzt weitere schnelle
zusätzliche lieferungen im herbst und
natürlich im winter damit die
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer sich jetzt
verteidigen können aber wir müssen uns
leider auch darauf einstellen dass der
krieg vielleicht auch im nächsten jahr
noch weiter gehen wird und deswegen
müssen wir kurzfristig unterstützen
schnell aber eben auch mittelfristig
planen und daher sind von herrn scholz
weitere lieferung auch für das jahr 2023
angekündigt zum beispiel bei dem
hochmodernen system iris t was jetzt in
den nächsten wochen geliefert werden
wird zur luftverteidigung gerade für
längere distanzen davon wird es weitere
systeme dann auch im nächsten jahr geben
und diese kurz und mittelfristigen
unterstützungsmaßnahmen die bedingen
einander und widersprechen einander
nicht man sieht es natürlich gerade auch
als außenministerin dass die letzten
monate viel enttäuscht porzellan
zerschlagen haben in osteuropa in polen
im baltikum da ist die enttäuschung über
die zögerlichkeit deutschlands groß also
wenn sogar ein lettischer
verteidigungsminister sagt das vertrauen
in deutschland hier das ist inzwischen
so close to zero also nahe null das ist
doch eigentlich für die deutsche
außenpolitik katastrophal
ich sehe das anders ehrlich gesagt
natürlich ist auch viel porzellan
zerschlagen aber es betrifft nicht die
letzten monate sondern die letzten jahre
und das ist ja das wo wir gesagt haben
wir brauchen hier auch eine andere
europa eine andere osteuropa politik
weil wir mit dem festhalten an
nordstream zwei als bundesrepublik
deutschland damals eben nicht auf die
sorge unser baltischen nachbarn und
freunde gehört haben weil wir zu beginn
der waffenlieferung ja eher zögerlich
gewesen sind diesen kurs haben wir aber
geändert auch gerade nach vielen
gesprächen mit unseren britischen
freunden mit unseren osteuropäischen
freunden und wir haben dinge die am
anfang nicht schnell genug gekommen sind
und so ehrlich müssen wir seien auf den
weg gebracht gerade mit blick auf den
ringtausch wo es gehapert hat sind die
verträge jetzt entsprechende
abgeschlossen schwere waffen wo es erst
zögerlich voran gegangen ist die liefern
wir jetzt gemeinsam und nichtsdestotrotz
weil in dieser situation kann man
einfach auch nichts schön reden müssen
wir immer wieder überprüfen wie wir
weiter gemeinsam unterstützen können ich
möchte an der stelle auch sagen das
waren die furchtbarsten monate die sich
menschen in der ukraine ja überhaupt
vorstellen konnten weil viele viele
menschen gestorben sind weil wir
gräueltaten gesehen haben die wir uns
niemals hätten vorstellen können auf dem
europäischen kontinent wir müssen aber
auch deutlich machen die wahnvorstellung
die der russische präsident hatte
nämlich dass er in ein paar tagen kiew
einnehmen kann und in den panzern von
russischen soldaten waren ja schon die
parade uniformen drin oder diese
propaganda dass man im osten der ukraine
feiern würde wenn russen kommen all das
ist nicht aufgegangen weil die
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer sich mutig
dem entgegengestellt haben mit ihrem
leben bezahlt haben aber auch weil wir
als europäer geschlossen und gemeinsam
eben militärische hilfe geleistet haben
wir es ins dieser wahnsinns plan putins
bisher zum glück nicht aufgegangen und
wir müssen auch weiterhin alles dafür
tun dass er niemals aufgeben wird
sondern im gegenteil auch die ukraine
wieder frei sein kann und irgendwann
ihren unabhängigkeitstag auch wieder
wirklich feiern sie wissen aber auch ein
sonnentag trauern muss sie wissen aber
auch dass es stimmen gibt die sagen man
sollte vielmehr auf eine
verhandlungslösung setzen und dabei auch
russische interessen stärker beachten
genau und zum jetzigen zeitpunkt vor
zeitpunkt halte ich das für nicht
richtig weil das würde genau dem
widersprechen was ihre fragen davor
waren und auch meine antworten darauf
niemand hat sich diesen krieg gewünscht
bis zum 23 februar vor einem halben jahr
haben wir alles dafür getan diesen krieg
zu verhindern diplomatisch zu verhindern
ich war selber paar wochen davor noch in
moskau beim russischen außenminister
habe gemeinsam darüber gesprochen wie
wir mit blick auf die krim auf die ost
ukraine endlich wieder verhandlungen
aufnehmen können aber der russische
präsident hat beschlossen genau diese
friedensgespräche zu zerstören jetzt
zerstört der seit sechs monaten ein
unschuldiges land und deswegen können
wir in dieser situation wo man von
russischer seite noch nicht einmal dazu
bereit ist über humanitäre korridore
wirklich umfänglich zu verhandeln können
wir derzeit vor allen dingen mit
waffenlieferungen die ukraine
unterstützen wir sehen das mit blick auf
die getreideexporte es wichtig ist dass
bei dem kleinsten funken hoffnung wo man
daraufsetzen kann dass irgendwas
überhaupt noch ins laufen kommen kann
dass jeder versuch es wert ist über die
vereinten nationen über internationale
akteure deswegen hat der bundeskanzler
ja auch immer mal wieder mit dem
russischen präsidenten gesprochen aber
sich darauf zu verlassen
irgendwann wird das schon aufhören das
kostet menschenleben und deswegen
unterstützen wir militärisch in dieser
situation und bestmöglich menschen leben
in der ukraine zu retten sagt die
deutsche außenministerin frau berg
danken für das gespräch danke ebenso
alles gute
nach schätzungen der vereinten nationen
hat der krieg mehr als elf millionen
menschen in die flucht getrieben
das aktionsbündnis deutschland hilft
sammelt für geflüchtete und die
kriegsopfer in der ukraine über den
spendenaufruf des zdf kam bereits 145
millionen euro zusammen wenn auch sie
helfen wollen können sie das über das
konto de 65 104 106 100 104 106 100
stichwort zdf nothilfe ukraine
ein großer krieg auf europäischem boden
geht auch an den anderen ländern des
kontinents nicht spurlos vorüber und mit
den wirtschaftlichen folgen beginnen
jetzt die nachrichten kaiser konkret mit
der energiekrise um strom und gas zu
sparen hat das bundeskabinett zahlreiche
maßnahmen beschlossen so dürfen büros in
öffentlichen gebäuden nur noch auf 19
grad geheizt werden flure möglichst gar
nicht mehr
repräsentative beleuchtung zum beispiel
von denkmälern oder schaufenstern wird
ebenso untersagt wie das beheizen
privater pools mit strom oder gas
außerdem müssen immobilienbesitzer ihre
heizungen regelmäßig prüfen lassen
um die versorgung von kohlekraftwerken
und raffinerien sicherzustellen sollen
energie transport auf der schiene
vorübergehend vorrang haben das könne im
zweifel bedeuten dass personenzüge
warten müssen so verkehrsminister
wissing die regierung brachte außerdem
ein gesetz zur kita-finanzierung auf den
weg damit soll vor allem die qualität
verbessert werden zum beispiel durch
gezielte sprachförderung oder bessere
betreuung schluss
vorgesehen sind für die kommenden zwei
jahre 4 milliarden euro als ziel nannte
familienministerin pauls bundesweite
standards die bisherigen bundesmittel
laufen ende dieses jahres aus
der frühere us-präsident schamp hat bei
seinem auszug aus dem weißen haus
offenbar mehr als 700 seiten geheimer
dokumente mitgenommen einige davon mit
der höchsten geheimhaltungsstufe
das geht aus einem brief des
nationalarchivs an trumps anwälte hervor
trump hatte die schriftstücke im januar
übergeben im august hatte das fbi auf
seinem anwesen in florida weitere
ebenfalls teils streng geheime dokumente
sichergestellt
möglicherweise machte sich trump durch
die mitnahme strafbar
seit jahren herrscht im sudan extreme
dürre und die macht sogar die regenzeit
zum problem denn die trockenen böden
können das wasser nicht aufnehmen
sturzfluten haben ganze landstriche
überschwemmt was 90 menschen kamen
dadurch seit mai ums leben in sechs von
18 provinzen wurde der notstand
ausgerufen
weltweite klimakatastrophen krieg in
europa und eine pandemie haben wir auch
noch es gab schon mal bessere zeiten
vielleicht liegt es auch daran dass
corona in der öffentlichen debatte in
den hintergrund getreten ist zu viel der
gleichzeitigkeit nur verschwunden ist
kroner deshalb ja leider nicht allein
für den letzten monat meldet das lka
mehr als 2800 krone toten weit mehr als
im juli letzten jahres
ob es bei steigenden zahlen im herbst
wieder ein dämmungsmaßnahmen gibt und
wenn ja welche darüber hat einen
gesundheits und justizminister wochen
lang verhandelt heute das bundeskabinett
ihrem gesetzentwurf abgesegnet aus
berlin peter spiekermann
es gibt unterschiedliche
interpretationen wann die maske zu
tragen ist der fdp justizminister sie
das liberal nur dann wenn es eng wird
kommt die maske zum zug lauterbach der
selbst ernannte minister des teams
vorsicht präsentiert sich heute quasi
dauer maskiert die beiden müssen einen
gemeinsamen weg finden zum
infektionsschutzgesetz und verstolpern
ihn beim thema schule die maßnahme dass
sich die kategorie schule pauschal
schließe die sieht das gesetz nicht vor
und offen gestanden das ist auch richtig
und wichtig so es sind natürlich denkbar
dass es eine variante gebe die also zum
beispiel ganz besonders kinder befällt
wenn dem so wäre dann kämen natürlich
der § 28a zum tragen und dann kehren wir
in eine ganz andere pandemische lagen es
setzte allerdings einem beschluss des
deutschen bundestages vor so ganz
einfach geht das nicht zwei männer zwei
haltungen sie können es nicht verbergen
und geben doch vor sich weitgehend einig
zu sein bundesweit soll daher ab dem
ersten
zehnten gelten dass also in den fern und
im flugverkehr fsb zwei masken getragen
werden müssen gerade nicht besonders
passend die bilder der kanada reise des
kanzlers und seines vizes pcr getestet
aber ohne maske die luftwaffe erlaubt
nach den tests was im normalen
flugverkehr unerlaubt ist ja es ist
ebenso es gibt eigene regeln für die
luftwaffe und für die flugbereitschaft
und die sind hier zum einsatz gekommen
politisch würde ich uns empfehlen als
bundesregierung dass wir überall die
gleichen regeln anwenden die auch sonst
gelten was soll ab oktober gelten für
alle wenig muss vieles kann sollte eine
corona welle kommen können die länder
die masken pflegt im nahverkehr in
schulen in der gastronomie bei kulturen
sportveranstaltungen ausweiten ausnahmen
frisch geimpfte und genesene könnten
ohne maske durchgehend für die länder
ist das zuviel kann und zu wenig muss
sie verlangen vom bund leitplanken es
würde einfach sinn machen zu sagen
abwasser monitoring incidents
hospitalisierung since it ends welche
gewichtung haben die
rk isar 1 das sind fragestellungen drin
da würde ich mir vom bund schon noch
gerne antworten wünschen nach den
ministern hat nun das parlament das wort
doch teile seiner eigenen partei wollen
nicht so wie er das will und lauterbach
er hätte gern viel mehr erreicht ziel
bleibt für den chor ohne ernstfall ein
gerüst das hält
und jetzt nochmal keine server mit dem
blick auf die wirtschaft ja die ja schon
gegen energiekrise gestörte lieferketten
und steigende preise kämpft jetzt kommt
auch noch der schwache euro dazu und
alles verstärkt sich gegenseitig seit 20
jahren war der euro-kurs nicht mehr so
niedrig und das dürfte spürbare folgen
haben valerie haller welche genau eine
zum beispiel dass urlaube in die usa
spürbar teurer werden rund 14 prozent
mehr als noch im sommer vor einem jahr
aber viel entscheidender
der schwache euro heizt die inflation
weiter an den waren die nach deutschland
eingeführt und in dollar abgerechnet
werden die werden jetzt auch teurer dazu
gehören so wichtige importe wie energie
also öl und gas und andere rohstoffe
also vor allem fürs tanken und heizen
müssen verbraucher womöglich noch tiefer
in die tasche greifen der euro steht
seit wochen unter druck bekam man im
januar für den euro noch einen dollar 37
ist er jetzt weniger als einen us-dollar
wert zum ersten mal seit 20 jahren ein
zustand an den wir uns vielleicht sogar
fürs erste gewöhnen müssen denn die
devisen experten gehen davon aus dass
der euro für längere zeit sogar eher
noch weiter fällt verschiedene faktoren
stärken den dollar die usa gelten als
stabileres anlage land gerade weil die
gasknappheit amerika weniger trifft als
europa in krisenzeiten sind sichere
häfen gefragt und das ist nun mal eher
der dollar und in den usa sind die
zinsen höher als in europa das macht die
dollar anlage attraktiver normalerweise
kurbelt ein schwacher euro die exporte
an weil sie dadurch eben auch billiger
werden doch die zeiten sind nicht normal
die energie und industrierohstoffe sind
so teuer dass der eigentliche vorteil
verpufft danke an die frankfurter börse
auf dem höhepunkt der kona pandemie war
die zahl der verkehrstoten auf einem
historischen tiefstand inzwischen ist
sie wieder deutlich gestiegen im ersten
halbjahr kamen 1200 38 menschen ums
leben und damit 12 prozent mehr als im
vorjahreszeitraum
die zahl der verletzten stieg um 20
prozent
die zahlen sind aber immer noch deutlich
niedriger als vor kona denn auf den
straßen ist immer noch weniger los als
damals möglicherweise wegen des neuen
euro tickets und der hohen spritpreise
die übrigens gerade wieder anziehen der
adac meldet deutlich höhere preise im
bundesdurchschnitt als noch vergangene
woche grund sei vermutlich eine höhere
nachfrage vor dem auslaufen des tank
rabatt in einer woche viele autofahrer
würden vor dem drohenden preissprung
noch einmal volltanken deshalb warnen
die tankstellenbetreiber in den
kommenden tagen auch vor längeren
wartezeiten schauen wir noch kurz auf
die lottozahlen wie immer ohne gewähr 7
15 26 34 40 49 superzahl 6 weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto zdf de
und im zdf text auf seite 55 7
die richtige gamer szene mag gerade auch
den älteren unter uns nach wie vor fremd
seien doch auch wer nur hin und wieder
mal mit dem handy unter konferenztisch
solitär spielt es ist ja letztendlich
auch ein gamer laut branchenverband
spielen immerhin mehr als die hälfte der
deutschen zwischen sechs und 69 jahren
videospiele der weltmarkt ist riesig die
umsätze sind es auch gaming ist längst
ein erheblicher wirtschaftsfaktor
geworden der auch von der
bundesregierung gefördert wird in köln
hat nun erstmals wieder seit der
pandemie die gamescom ihre tore geöffnet
und dominik müller sl hat sich dort
umgesehen
es sind glorreiche zeiten für die
games-branche während der pandemie ist
der spielemarkt explodiert vom sofa aus
monster bekämpfen und sich in ganz
fremden welten verlieren dafür war viel
zeit und anscheinend auch bedarf
und nun also zum ersten mal wieder
zusammenkommen um die gemeinsame
leidenschaft zu zelebrieren viele gamer
sind geflasht
die gamescom die größte spielemesse der
welt doch von dem spiele boom haben
bislang vor allem die großen blockbuster
studios profitiert etwa aus den usa
kanada oder auch frankreich wo der staat
die entwicklung von spielen großzügig
unterstützt für deutsche anbieter bei
der weg bis lang steinig und schwer das
könnte sich nun allerdings ändern wir
haben die aufholjagd begonnen weil auch
die bundesregierung sich entschieden hat
mit games förderung zu installieren wo
wir einfach wettbewerbsfähige
bedingungen haben und wir sehen dass
ganz viele unternehmen gründen sich neue
ganz viele fachkräfte kommen dazu und
das wirklich eine gute ausgangsposition
für die nächsten jahre wenn die ampel
regierung hat sich nach lässt sondern
weiter die standortbedingungen schafft
die wir brauchen mit knapp 50 millionen
euro fördert die bundesregierung die
deutschen spieleentwickler jährlich es
gibt hier auch darum
zukunftstechnologien zu unterstützen und
programmierer im land zu halten und die
kleinen studios wiederum sind froh über
jeden cent wenn sie ein spiel auf den
markt bringen wollen hat das mit seinem
spieldorf romantik geschafft
juni erstmals dem studium kommt hat
natürlich nicht so viel kapital worauf
man zurückgreifen kann und für die
spieleentwicklung braucht man ja
eigentlich erst mal so ein puffer damit
man ein oder zwei jahre erstmal
überbrücken kann und davon leben kann
und da haben wir auf eine förderung
beantragt und die haben wir bekommen und
dann konnten wir eben die entwicklung
von dort romantik vereinen ja erstmal
damit sozusagen finanzieren
und dann liegt es hat doch alles ganz
gut ein entschleunigen das puzzlespiel
das seinen markt gefunden hat und ein
gegentrend zum adrenalin und zur
bombastic die die branche auf ihrem
größten treffen wieder feiern
das war es von uns gleich folgt das
auslandsjournal heute unter anderem mit
einer reportage aus andalusien wo die
avocado bäume vertrocknen und den
letzten blick auf diesen nachrichten tag
hat wohl schmiese um halb eins im
heute-journal update schönen abendessen
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend die nacht wird im westen
klar und da sinken die temperaturen zum
teil nicht unter 20 grad deutlich kühler
wird die nacht am alpenrand mit neun
grad die höchsttemperaturen morgen
liegen zwischen 24 grad an der ostsee
und 35 grad am niederrhein im westen
gibt es die sonne richtung osten sind
die wolken etwas zahlreicher und da
könnte es am nachmittag mal für einen
regen schauer oder ein kurzes gewitter
erreichen freitag und samstag bringen
dann unwetter das können gewitter seien
die mit hagel platzregen und sturmböen
verbunden sind am sonntag aber beruhigt
sich die lage von westen und auch wenn
es jetzt erstmal kühler wird der august
wird wohl rekord warm die warmen sommer
werden bei uns häufiger und in
kontinentaleuropa sind es die alten die
sich durch die globale
temperaturerhöhung besonders dramatisch
und schnell verändern
offensichtlich durch den
gletscherschwund als beispiel hier die
pasterze am großglockner in österreich
seit beginn der industrialisierung haben
die alpengletscher etwa ein drittel
ihrer masse verloren ziehen sich die
wichtigen süßwasser speicher zurück
hinterlassen sie mulden die sich mit
schmelzwasser füllen ein gletschersee
entsteht touristisch durchaus attraktiv
aber sehr gefährlich sind die felsen
brüchig kann ein see ausbrechen das
wasser stürzt in die tiefe und kann in
engen tälern weiler fluten wenn alle
gletscher verschwinden fehlt auch das
schmelzwasser das im frühjahr und sommer
flüsse füllt auf wiedersehen